hello to you mr shep thanks very much
indeed for joining us on the program
lots to talk to you about but i want to
talk about the rail strikes to start
with this morning if
i may why have these negotiations failed
essentially the unions
do not want to
modernize uh the work practices so we
can run the modern railway uh for
passengers essentially they've been
taking the passengers for a ride with
some of these antiquated um methods that
are in place for example not being able
to send out a single van having to send
two vans to maintenance and not running
a seven day service for example we have
to literally on some railway lines um
appeal to
uh the better nature of staff to even
run a railway service on a sunday and
that can't be right in the 21st century
when leisure travel actually is the
bigger part becoming the bigger part of
the transport network so we have to have
this modernization it's there to be
sorted out and and therefore pay rise
can be had as well but i'm afraid the
unions have been incredibly militant
about this and that's where we are where
we are today
and the unions are saying that um they
haven't spoken to a minister
for months when was the last time you
spoke to them
they don't need to speak to ministers to
resolve this because their employers are
the people who have the uh mandate to
negotiate this they're the people who uh
they can resolve this with so this is
just i'm afraid then uh trying to
distract attention and if i put this
into perspective since i've been
transport secretary they've issued about
160 different disputes there hasn't been
a single day where there hasn't been
either strike action or a mandate for
strike action uh ongoing that's just not
normal in any industry and that's why we
need to i'm afraid do more
to remove the power of these very
militant extreme left unions from
disrupting everyday lives to ordinary
people
um how much involvement does the
government have on the funding of
network rail
yeah so we set the mandate just as we
would for you know for example for the
nhs or for any other public service but
it is for the employers
and the unions to resolve these things
simply for the fact that they're you
know incredibly detailed um discussions
uh that you know the unions know can
only be resolved with their employees so
of course we set the overall mandate
that's the whole point of a government
spending uh taxpayers money but the only
negotiation can be
with the employers themselves who have a
mandate but i'm afraid the unions don't
want to know about it as i say they've
been taking passengers for a ride on
this for far too long and that's one of
the reasons why we've started on the on
the on the road to introducing
legislation we've just made two
legal changes law changes uh to and
start to make the service run better
even when there are strikes on
okay so you set the mandate you're in
charge of the purse strings but you
think you can wash your hands of any
negotiations to try and sort this out
question of washing my hands is i'm not
the right person to be in the room
negotiating i i i with great respect i'm
not the person to discuss for example
the maintenance schedules of uh
individual groups of workers
in situations where for example they
have to send out an entire roster to do
a job that may just require uh one or
two people um but uh only the employer
would have the technical detail to they
have in those discussions there simply
is no reason uh to for the unions to be
speaking to anybody other than the
employers
and by the way it's never happened in
the past i i know what could learn going
back to
disputes during the the blair and brown
years um the unions were never in the
room i note in london where the rmt are
on strike and there is a labour mayor uh
the
mayor is not in the room or if he is
it's not working
because those strengths
yes he is yes
he's in london it is
oh okay okay that's interesting in
london in london it's for the mayor to
to
set the overall um you know if you like
the overall pay budget the overall
mandate yeah that's for the mayor okay
um so just to clarify at no stage will
you even if this rumbles on will you get
involved
it's just a game by the unions uh they
know that they don't know
there's a game by the unions it's a
complete red herring as well by the way
and it's simply not how strikes are
resolved it can only ever be
the employer in this case network rail
the train operating companies and the
unions by the way the union should
actually put these offers to their
members um the unions have an offer on
the table network rail which is around
eight percent uh for the next two years
this year and next year based on
actually carrying out these
modernizations which are decades overdue
um and they didn't even bother to put it
to their members they simply called
another strike that can't be right it's
one of the reasons why one of the
changes i'd be looking to bring in would
be to limit the ability to carry on
taking strike strike action under a
single mandate which can be cheated
which can have been called as much as
six months earlier so we've got to
modernize these union laws i'm afraid
given that every single person watching
every household watching your program
spend 600 pounds to ensure that not a
single rail worker was left unemployed
or even had to go on furlough
during the
pandemic this is one heck of a way to
repay hard working viewers by going on
strike even when a payoff is on the
table okay when modernization is what's
required okay let me let me just ask you
for a thought on this um not really your
remit but i'm sure you've got a view
shadow transport minister uh sam terry
uh we're being told he's on the picket
line uh at houston this morning what do
you think
almost clearly in direct defiance of uh
shakir stamina who's told his front
bench that they shouldn't be so we'll
leave that disciplinary action to secure
no doubt he'll want to remove him from
his job look nobody should be on the
picket lines stopping hard-working
people who spent i mentioned 600 pounds
per family that works out to 160 000
pounds per rail worker preventing any of
them from losing their jobs during the
pandemic we come out the pandemic and
this is the way that people are being
thanked and if labor from benchers want
to go and join them on the picket line
where people will come to their own
conclusions i have no doubt secure star
will want a second